i'm cynthia mcfadden I work for ABC News
as a co-anchor of Nightline and as a
co-anchor of primetime live I was
adopted as a baby by two really
wonderful people my mother and father
had tried repeatedly to have children
and weren't able to and I would say was
sort of cider house rules the local
doctor dr. twaddle if you can believe it
suggested to my parents that he was
going to have some babies available I
was a private arrangement in the spring
of nineteen fifty six and so one night
after visiting hours my parents went to
the nursery and there were three little
girl babies one of whom was screaming
that one was me and the nurse picked me
up handed me to my mother and my mother
said Warren I think this is our baby and
they took me home of course Dadaab Shin
has changed a great deal in the
intervening 51 years but I was blessed I
was blessed to be taken by two people
who really wanted a child and I was only
child and I was told by these two
wonderful people that I could do
anything I wanted to do and that made
enormous difference in my life I was the
first person to my family to go to
college and that was really through
their belief in me and I went to Boden
which was down the road from where I
grew up in Maine which had recently when
I went I was in the third class of women
to graduate from Boden and a local judge
in town of this little town of Auburn
where I grew up said to me well I don't
approve of women going to Boden but if
they're going to be there you should be
one of them so with that sort of dubious
encouragement I was lucky enough to be
admitted to Boden which was still pretty
much a men's school that admitted women
but it it developed my should i say
confidence or fierceness i guess both
maybe it made me realize that i could
stand on my own two feet that i didn't
always have to seek the approval of
others that my opinion mattered and
I went to law school not because I
wanted to be a lawyer I went to law
school because I wanted to be a
journalist and I had no idea how to go
about doing that so one of my professors
said well god knows you never stop
talking and you write pretty well so go
study something that you're interested
in whatever that might be and I was very
interested in government and the way the
law worked and so applied to law school
and it's funny my law school essay was
about wanting to be a journalist it was
so odd that the Dean of Admissions at
Columbia called me and said are you sure
you got the right place here we're
inclined to admit you but it seems a it
seems an odd track it didn't seem odd to
me at all and in fact that was sort of
let's say I graduate from law school in
84 so I was applied in nineteen eighty
that was years before cable television
and the advent of every lawyer Tom Dick
and Mary being on television this was a
way ahead of that so so I believe that
the law was too important to leave to
the lawyers that we needed to have
civilian journalists who knew something
about the law enough to ask probing
questions and that's what sent me to
Columbia
you